Aujourd'hui à Paris il fait 28 degrés et c'est le début du printemps
Tout le monde sort et tout le monde est un peu beau gosse
Parce que ça fait ça le soleil
Et moi je me suis dit que j'allais en profiter pour devenir un mec, un vrai, genre
un peu viril et tout
bon je crois que c'est plutôt réussi
*FAUX*
*instru*
* LA VIRILITÉ *
Tout d'abord, Je me suis procuré un after shave
Dans la publicité ils disent que c'est censé apaiser après le feu du rasoir
Alors j'ai essayé
BRAAAAAHAAAAH!!!
ça ne marche pas du tout
ça fait l'effet parfaitement inverse
En fait ça te brule totalement l'intégralité du visage
et eux ils disent que ça apaise, hein...
P*****
Après je me suis décidé à faire de la muscu
Comme ça je serai un petit peu muclé et tout heu...
Beau gosse aight!!
Moi à chaque fois que j'essaie de faire de la muscu
Je me dis je vais faire progressivement tu vois, genre heu
Lundi un petit peu, mardi un petit peu, mercredi
Le problème c'est que t'a souvent un pote qui dit que pour bien se muscler
il faut que ça fasse mal un peu et tout
et c'est à ce moment là que le muscle il travaille
alors moi j'y vais comme un ouf tu vois
*AH CA FAIT BIEN MAL C'EST BIEN
Et là le lendemain j'ai carrément mal pendant une semaine
Ton corps est absolument douloureux
et je suis pas plus musclé
Voilà pourquoi moi je fais de la muscu un jour dans l'année
Je sais qu'il y a un type de mec vachement viril qui plait aux meuf, c'est les brun ténébreux
Et le brun ténébreux, j'ai jamais trop capté pourquoi il était ténébreux, tu vois ?
Toi t'est normal et lui il est ténébreux
Dans ma tête j'ai l'impression que le mec quand il se réveil le matin, il est comme ça :
Euhh, il reste du café sans sucre ?
Alors que les blond, ils pourront jamais être ténébreux
Non mais c'est vrai, on entend jamais dire : les roux ténébreux, les chauves ténébreux ...
Non, ça n'existe pas ! A c'est du racisme je suis désolé, je suis désolé !
Moi je pourrait, je pourrait jamais être ténébreux
Enfin pour être un mec vraiment viril, je pense qu'il faudrait que je fasse un certain nombre de truc qu' on dois faire quand on est viril
Un peu comme le mec qui pour te dire bonjour te serre la main super fort .
Un truc super chiant d’ailleurs !
Eaaahh, j'ai gagné !
Eh les gars, c'est pas un combat, j'veux dire... Ou alors ouvrir une canette de bière avec un briquet par exemple.
Moi j'arrive jamais !
Excuse-moi, est ce que tu peux m'aider à l'ouvrit ste'plait ?
Quoi ?! Tu sais pas l'ouvrir?
Tiens
Merci
A cet instant, j'ai vraiment l'air d'une bite
Ou encore craquer mes doigts
Moi, ça ne fait aucun bruit
Tant pis je ne serais jamais un mec viril...
*pfffffff*
Des fois j'ai envie de tout plaquer et de partir vivre aux states , commencer ma carrière de vétérinaire...
Mais bon avec le recule... J'me dis que c'est un peu con
Comme vous êtes de plus en plus nombreux sur ma page facebook "Norman fait des vidéos"
Peut-être qu'après on pourrait faire, tous ensemble, une manifestation sur un thème
En fin je sais pas comme vous voulez.
ÇA VA ÊTRE SUPER BIEN!!!
*Beatbox*
Dis bonjour sergi!
ONE TWO !